See, writer's block just doesn't exist.
This is the reality of what happens.
Okay, so you open up your computer and
you check your email and then you got a
billion Slack messages and then you've
got 10 tabs open, 20 tabs open. I'm
being generous here. And you know, you
browse Twitter a little bit. Then then
you you got your phone on your desk. So
then you start scrolling Instagram. And
in between all of those little
activities, you dabble a little bit of
writing here. You're like, I'm going to
do some research.
hash out that idea a little bit more and
after an hour you've got maybe you know
a hundred words written down and you're
like exhausted and your brain is burnt.
This this is exactly why like a year ago
I bought this typewriter thing from a
freewrite. It was it's called a
freewrite traveler. You all you can do
is just type. That's it. I go sit at my
writing desk with a cup of coffee with
the typewriter. My phone's in a
different room. There's no tabs. There's
none of those distractions. Nothing like
that. And you will be shocked how fast
you blow through 500 words, a thousand
words, 2,000 words, 3,000 words because
you all you can do is type. It is that
simple that if you just give yourself
the space to think and write, there is
no writer's block. What's blocking you
is the distraction of all the modern-day
technology that they say is helpful to
make you efficient and more productive,
but all it is doing is killing your
ability to think clearly.